what's up dude
so I thought it was you man are you
doing good how are you it's good to see
it you all trim em n fun what are you
doing around here I'm doing my rounds my
agents in that building over there so I
was just meeting with her a little cool
there with the same agent that sense it
I think or not um yeah good you know i'm
just i'm probably gonna be leaving town
next week a little hiatus just the folks
but how was it she's their good will
tell your mom she's gonna see me on TV
next season what one of those stupid
reality shows like come for when the
major networks some guy he saw me and I
think Hail Mary and love what I did any
cats mate who said come in read and next
thing I know at my table read yesterday
i'm on this year and you know we should
talk all about it you know you still
have same number um you know what why
don't you give me a call call me I will
I will I can't police cruiser live in
the same [ __ ] I can't believe it it's
great I see right okay okay
you
Milo Milo Milo Milo trying to get a
whole you man third time through tunnels
we gotta talk to you man guys got gotta
gotta get together we're gonna do a leg
in and out style of innocent like that
hey listen I gotta I gotta grab this
call call me I don't hit me hit me back
holla back I hey Morgan hi how's the
baby she's so cute i really i really
love their time together thank you so
much
will I hope to see you saturday I cheer
me hello hello all right
you cool here by yourself good cuz I
gotta piss
haha MattyB what's up babe man what you
been up to me doing a damn thing this is
that right doing the damn thing so
what's up look at you man texting Denzel
Washington those well no it's not like
that man i got this whole like a
two-week pullmantur going on i think so
did you hear the radio a minute nah huh
you didn't tell me that yeah where it
was how was so what's up in mom's old
man how's she doing he asked about you I
was like I didn't know I didn't know
what to tell her man she's still making
a metallized yeah are you Megan yeah
that's that's real real good you know
I'm happy huh I'm happy about everything
really am you know I really happy with
everything about what yeah you or me no
I'm just I'm just I'm just happy that
I'm happy that finally you know like
these dreams just like I'll become a
truly damn you know this is publicist
Beth turn its you got two events for any
man let's just at a time let's just set
a day in time you know let's just do
that right now by your say come over
come on man no seriously you know you
mean you got a secretary of color and
I'll set it up I gotta run man I think
the shuttles outside weird for me now um
I'm gonna hit you in about two weeks man
and then on me like I said it's good to
see you man you're looking good man
obviously still ballin damn man yo don't
let it be that long next time that's
crazy finally made it man you know you
can get this you good to see you we made
it we made it baby maybe you made I'll
write two weeks and I'm hit you okay
yeah cool man hey tell moms i said look
I tell okay I'm an alto guys like what
yeah
I cannot feel it anymore sports
Demetrius will pull shot himself last
wish it goes home dunno I here that'll
be the [ __ ] why didn't stop overreacting
do we overreact the more it gets blown
out before she moves it's away from the
truth the truth is you just have to
treat this as like a clip in the rate of
life you have so much going for you why
ruin it with just just one moment
tonight you
haven't let anyone
to a hospital
national and Astra
but I was led here and so fine if you're
going to if you're going to throw me
into LA and you're going to throw me
into an acting class and i'm going to do
a scene and you're going to like my
acting work then why am I here seven
years later wondering was it all worth
it took about leaving
no just just just regretting
ready oh really
I never had where would I be in life if
I had never decided to do this
I've spent seven years of my life
as sort of a soon hasn't quite reached
their dream and he had a couple of tough
months recently but I didn't realize
that that you were like at this point
cuz
I mean everything's good a few no I'm
still grinding away I'm still you know
I'm everything's cool just I just you
know value here was you know some some
what about someone of a mentor
hi I was actually we're just got you I
literally just like walked up here and
wow I'm like and I mean what so you
still live here yeah I mean I haven't
seen you
you I know this is weird but you can I
just come around and guess it in that
pasture secret I just actually no you
know I cannot just get out let's yeah
let's go okay
wow what I know right what what are you
doing here what hi all right hi well
first of all how are you still teaching
yeah yeah how are the kids great that's
great everything's great yeah I'm doing
really great good well yeah really great
yeah okay good yeah and I and roommate
to cook dinner what I i live with my
mate and my my my god not the mike
difficulty no no not for now I just off
Philippe actually it yesterday so he's
good well okay and and everything's good
with I mean everything's good with me
like as far as you know you know the
[ __ ] the film you know that film I did
was is kind of like we're editing it
you know and I'm still sure why so I
don't feel it's like how does someone
like desperately want to get somewhere
but yet it's never going to be within
reach if you wake up and you no longer
authentically have a need to express
love and the beauty strength and courage
and the it's all those wonderful things
that you and I've shared in our
conversations and our experiences when
we've gone to see films when we talked
if that's no longer inside you that that
that need to just
give yourself over to a role that's the
only answer that's the only reason that
you can walk away from it if there's
anything inside you that still feels
that same need that God should come out
here to be an actor in the first place
then you have to stick with it but if
that's gone then that only means that
that you're gonna find another means to
to to fulfill that need that you have I
have so many things this week's been
crazy we we just we make a choice and
then years later we think why did I do
that and that's and that's what I'm
thinking right now especially this week
I'm like why did I do that our lives
would have been
that you don't have to you know no for
that but no but seriously what mission I
want well I mean how long did it take
you to get over man no it's a long wow
that's really not your business the days
I feel like I gotta go I am dinner well
would you hold on just just take this de
banco it's a car just
all I can say to you is that the place
you're at right now with that sense of
purpose lessness desolation or am I
wasting my life I have the same exact
thoughts
doing what I'm doing but what if what if
all of a sudden acting dried up for you
what if all of a sudden you couldn't you
couldn't get Mac dinky I mean well what
would you do if you start reevaluating
idiots would you yes I would have to I
mean it would be essential implicit or
else I wouldn't be able to survive I
love you for who
I know that's a strike coming out here
to this town billboards everywhere
movies this that maple salaries no
[ __ ] and people esteem going on the
right call may cause the [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] it's not even about anybody else I
I think less of myself
I'm never gonna get rid of that
bitterness towards myself for not
fulfilling the dream and I set out to
accept and that's your answer
you're not ready to walk away I honor
that
spec trust that truth beside yourself
because all that tree is going to come
pouring out one day somebody's going to
finally realize what you have to give
it's a lot it's beautiful and it's a
value for you more than anything else no
matter what they do or how they choose
it soon
but it stay
let it stay pure that's the greatest
challenge out here it's not getting the
job staying pure have it means help do
you